en corea del norte crece la preocupación
por la epidemia intestinal aguda que se
suma al brote de kobe 19 los medios
estatales del hermético país asiático
notificaron un brote de infecciones en
el suroeste de la nación que coincide
además con un momento donde aún continúa
la vigente ola de coronavirus más de
23.000 personas fueron registradas por
fiebres sospechosas la situación
sanitaria es delicada la agencia central
de noticias de corea aseguró que el
líder norcoreano kim jong-un y otros
funcionarios o crearon paquetes de ayuda
para al menos unas 800 familias que son
víctimas de esta epidemia intestinal no
identificada la cacn detalló que la
asistencia elaborada por el gobierno
incluye medicamentos y también alimentos
para paliar esta afección estas familias
están radicadas en la ciudad de jeju y
el condado de canyon en el suroeste de
corea del norte y por su parte de corea
del sur está entonces llevando a cabo
una investigación para así monitorear el
origen del brote
podría ser cólera o fiebre tifoidea
según explicó un funcionario del
ministerio de unificación surcoreano
saludamos entonces a nuestro segundo
invitado del día un invitado de la casa
el socio franco profesor titular de
epidemiología y salud pública de la
universidad de berna harvard y también
erasmo de rotterdam además director del
instituto de medicina preventiva y
social de berna doctor muy buen día
gracias por estar con nosotros son un
día más aquí en directo marca de france
24 como saber doctor que realmente está
ocurriendo en corea del norte en materia
sanitaria un país tan hermético y que
digamos vota poca información sobre el
lo que le ocurre en todas luces en todas
sus áreas y por supuesto la salud no es
ajena
si la verdad es un hermetismo absoluto y
que se ha ampliado desde que tuvimos el
problema de kobe desde hace dos años el
cierre fue completo se cerraron las
fronteras se cerró la comunicación con
con china que era la frontera que hay
que comparten de más de 1400 kilómetros
donde se hacían mucho del tráfico ilegal
e ilegal que mantiene el comercio
norcorea y lo que sabemos es básicamente
especulaciones son rumores son los datos
que da el gobierno de norcorea y son lo
que lo que oyen los desertores lo que
comunican los de sectores cuando crucen
la frontera surcorea es lo que creo y lo
que parece que está ocurriendo es una
grave crisis humanitaria que no
solamente está el hobbit que no
solamente está este brote de fiebre
intestinal como se había llamado sino
también que han vivido unos meses unos
años con unas hambrunas debido a sequías
que han ocurrido en el país al cierre de
este país de 5 millones de habitantes el
doctor le pregunto digamos en el caso de
afecciones tifoideas cómo se pudiera
tratar y cómo se generaría más como cómo
reacciona como reacciona en el tienen en
el cuerpo y también le preguntó cómo se
puede tratar en un país con unas
condiciones sanitarias tan precarias la
falta de medicamentos
si un país que está completamente
debilitado también por el aspecto
económico porque como se hace roble el
intercambio comercial con con china y
las decisiones que se han tomado pues
han cerrado completamente al país por
ultramar por ferrocarril por río
etcétera la verdad no sabemos si fiebre
tifoidea no sabemos si es cólera parece
que es una fiebre intestinal como la
llamada al mismo kobe le llaman fiebres
de origen desconocido que parece que sea
por falta de pruebas no sabemos que lo
que está ocurriendo realmente entonces
no sabemos las necesidades que tienen y
si sabemos que debido a lo que ha
ocurrido en abril y mayo cork con la
gran el primer brote de kobe con más de
4.6 millones de personas reportadas como
con fiebres desconocidas pues que el
sistema de salud básicamente debe estar
muy afectado y de tener muchos problemas
para poder ayudar a esas 800 familias
que se han reportado como afectadas por
estas fiebres intestinales doctor
también hablabas de por supuesto la
hambruna no la falta de alimentos
también que padece de corea del norte le
quiero decir si también digamos la falta
de nutrientes la falta una buena
alimentación de esta población como
incurre y crece el riesgo de que
contraigan estas y otras enfermedades
si las nutriciones son sustratos un
factor que determina nuestra capacidad
de poder defendernos contra las
enfermedades y sabemos que norcorea ha
experimentado este tipo de situaciones
durante muchos años entre 1994 y 1998
ocurrió lo que se llamaba la marcha del
sufrimiento la gran hambruna de norcorea
y sabemos que tienen problemas no
solamente con la suministro sino con la
producción entonces es muy posible que
la población en general esté bajo una
situación bastante complicada que se
hayan afectado además por la crisis
económica las crisis políticas el kobe y
ahora con esa manutención subyacente
pues hace que las personas sean mucho
más vulnerables a adquirir enfermedades
hablabas también doctor de la pandemia
del hobbit 19 que se suman a esta
infección intestinal no identificada
nombrada por así por el por el gobierno
norcoreano cuál es la situación de la
pandemia de kobe 19 le pregunto también
si hay un regido un registro mucho mayor
de lo que dicen actualmente las
autoridades norcoreanas
si no no sabemos a ciencia cierta qué es
lo que está ocurriendo lo que hasta
ahora se ha sabido es que la política
que no corea era acero kobe cerraron
herméticamente las fronteras el comercio
no se reportó ningún caso hasta este año
y es que este año en enero abre
nuevamente la frontera con china debido
a las necesidades económicas parece que
por ahí quizás haya entrado el virus a
norcorea a pesar de todos los cuidados
las desinfecciones de mercancía etcétera
que se ha hecho luego ocurre en dos
fechas importantes en abril el 15 de
abril que se celebraron los 110 años del
fundador de norcorea y el 25 de abril
que se celebrarán 90 años de la
fundación del ejército esto se llevó a
eventos muy grandes principalmente la
capital envió ya en donde se veía a la
gente en grandes multitudes sin
distanciamiento sin tapabocas y desde
entonces en mayo se vio un aumento muy
marcado y se reportaron 4.6 millones de
casos en un país de 25 millones de
habitantes y teniendo en cuenta que no
sabemos la calidad transparencia de los
datos que venden por el entonces es
posible que la crisis sea aún peor de lo
que se ha reportado con estas precarias
condiciones en materia de salud y pues
en otras en otros ámbitos como lo tiene
corea del norte también como él hablamos
doctor digamos cuáles son los escenarios
y cuáles son las medidas que pueden
adoptar las autoridades para tratar de
evitar la propagación de estas
enfermedades o como lo han hecho
anteriormente como han salido digamos de
estos males
hasta ahora han dependido muchísimo de
la ayuda de china
china ha estado contribuyendo con
medicamentos con equipos respiradores
sin embargo los norcoreanos no han
recibido vacunas ni de china ni de
kóvacs del sistema de la organización
mundial de la salud es posible que
ninguna persona en este país esté
vacunada no se sabe si se está
produciendo vacunas lo más seguro es que
no entonces lo que estamos viendo es una
situación que podría ser muy delicada al
mismo tiempo tenemos que entender que la
mayoría de las decisiones si no todas
las decisiones pasan por el partido de
los trabajadores y por el bien supremo
que yo lo entonces no sabemos si esta
situación también tenga que ver con unas
circunstancias políticas y con la
complicación geopolítica que ocurrió en
el mundo